hey guys what's up i'm so excited for
you to watch this interview before we
get into this interview i want to talk
about our sponsor
prime xbt if you're trading bitcoin
you got to be using primex bt not only
do they have global markets
available to anyone but they also have
great execution
low fees and an amazing user interface
the best part about primex bt is that
you can also follow some of the best
traders in the world
you go on you find someone who you think
is smart and you can literally just
follow their trades when they execute
something your portfolio executes the
same
and if you think you're one of the best
traders in the world then you can simply
go on there and have people follow you
and you earn a little extra income by
having those followers
so if you're trading bitcoin anywhere in
the world you got to use primex bt
they've won multiple awards for being
one of the best trading platforms
in crypto you can trade spot markets or
even use margin
so go on over to use primexpt you can go
to the description and click on the link
there
all right let's get into this episode
today i really hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got a
special treat for you today justin is
here thank you so much for doing this
sir
hey hey how you doing man thanks for
having me on man absolutely you've got
this incredible story
uh just in life and then also uh kind of
with your relationship
with bitcoin let's start with kind of
your background tell us where did you
grow up and they kind of walk us through
your life
until about 25 years old okay
uh well i grew up in charlotte north
carolina
uh home of the charlotte hornets not my
favorite team though i'm a lakers fan
by the way mama mentality um and
growing up i was
i was always a bit of a different child
um i've been through different
situations in my life
um one particular that really stood out
it was life-changing
well fast back track i grew up a
basketball player loved to play
basketball
um got into a lot of different didn't
really get into too many different
sports outside that
probably ran a little track but um
i always had uh i always had that
inkling to want to be great at something
i didn't know what the hell it was
right so it was always something there
that i wanted to happen we just didn't
know how
and i didn't really understand it then
but that process officially
started my senior year in high school
when i was in 2006.
um me and my mother our house was
foreclosed on in 2006 my senior year
when i was wanting to go play uh college
ball try to compete for a state
championship
uh the summer before that i was waking
up at like 5 a.m
every day to train i was really
something i wanted to go
show myself on and when that situation
didn't happen
you know we lost the home had to
transfer to school when i transferred
there
i got there selected to play basketball
i was still able to hang around the team
you know
coach respected me you know i could play
so he said hey you know you'll still be
good camaraderie
um but then we know we were just hanging
out um
had a few friends of west charlotte and
we would go out and party every weekend
and it was crazy that they allowed us
that we actually did some stuff we did
at 17
um but one weekend in particular one of
my friends was still
his name was travis moore it was on
february 18th
and uh that was a very life-changing
moment
and so when that happened to me i was
like okay um
you know i there was really no coping
you know there wasn't too much cup in
the neighborhood
a lot of times people say hey that's
part of life you don't have to get over
it's like how the hell do you get over
that at 17. so uh luckily
i was still able to graduate high school
with the north carolina a
t um and i had gone there for two years
and college was fun because i had a lot
of fun in college i wasn't the guy who
did all the school work
i was partying chasing the girl
again i went to class sometimes though i
did go to class
um i actually made the dean's list
uh one year one semester in school but
then
immediately after i dropped out of
school um reason being
finances was making me make crazy
decisions while in college it was hard
to focus
um more importantly it was one time i
was in class and i was a business major
and this my professor he was throwing up
this graph
showing like everybody potential jobs
and whatnot and he said uh well you know
there won't be any jobs for you all
available to like
four years after graduation and i sat
there for a minute like wait did i
just hear this correct and everybody in
this in the classroom were just going
along like yeah that's cool okay that's
great and i said yo what the hell are we
doing
here i said uh i remember blatantly in
orientation
you saying that well not you but it's
being said that six months after
graduation stalin made or someone's
gonna want their money from these for
the loans we acquired here so
why would we want to wait that long to
start paying on
it didn't really make sense to me then i
started noticing the world in a
different lens
um so that was that was that semester i
decided like you know what i'm just
gonna drop out of school because
i felt like i was being taken advantage
of a little bit
you know i didn't i don't like that at
all when i ever
whenever i cinch that into someone or a
situation i want to
really regain that control over the
situation
but i did that in a stupid way by
dropping out of school so then when i
dropped out of school i went back home
to charlotte i had really no plan
uh i was just thinking about how i was
going to make it i was going to roll
into a lucky situation with money
um that did not happen and i ended up
making decisions that led me to go to
prison for three years
so in 2011 i got i got locked
i got arrested at 20 years old i was
sent off to prison at 21.
and when i was going to prison and when
i got there i was just thinking to
myself like damn
you really messed up all right um
but however i wasn't really down on
myself too much
i felt that i could i couldn't make a
comeback on whatever it was i always had
self-confidence
no matter what it was um you know i
would look up to athletes like
tom brady floyd mayweather told me like
i mentioned
and it wasn't just because the fact they
were always winning but it was about
what they
battled through to get you know what did
you vow to get
and um sitting in prison you know i had
to do a lot of learning about myself i
did a lot of reading
i tackled a lot of situations uh i did i
ran i ran a few
hustles on the yard as well just kept my
mind going i was always working out i
was always trying to stay uh
stay ahead as much as i could and so
when the time came for me you know to
start getting closer for home people
asking me justin what are you going to
do when you go out of prison i don't
know but i plan on making a billion
dollars doing it
man you crazy you know you don't know
what the hell you know about this like
man
i don't really care what you think i'm
going to do it because i said it
because if i felt i feel like this if i
say i'm going to do it
then it can't get done it's just how
we're going to get it done and so
um you know a lot of people
ask me what do i have planned i don't
have anything planned because i don't
know what's out there
so when i came home from prison in 2014
it was
a very it was a very rough situation um
i
tried to apply for jobs all around
charlotte
i got denied everywhere because of my
record i even got denied from working
for two men in the truck
i actually said so i can't work for a
moving company he said no we can't hire
you
damn this is gonna get kind of rough
then so um
eventually i started doing some other
type of work like retail merchandise
i would um like work 12 an hour 12 hours
a day
and i just started noticing how me being
in this position
made me put me in a position to be taken
advantage of by people
you know who think well you don't have
this credibility you don't have a degree
you have this record but you are
you can do this work right here and in
my mind i always felt like yo i'm better
than this type of work
i don't feel comfortable with calling
you a supervisor because i feel more
intelligent
so i always look for ways that i could
branch out into entrepreneurs
entrepreneurship i did not know so it
didn't it didn't start taking serious
until
i i was about to i found out my
girlfriend that time i was pregnant with
my first daughter
and i was like all right but something
clicked in you it was like you know
you have to start being different than
in the situation you're currently in
i started noticing everything around
around me like
i started noticing my network of people
i started noticing everybody around me
had the same problems nobody was really
getting
out of that problem and i wanted to fix
it
so um so eventually one day
i decided i was watching i was online on
instagram
and i would see a lot of algorithms
sending me stuff about dr savion being
vegan
and it was interesting to me but it was
it was strange but it was interesting
it was interesting enough because now a
lot of people knew how to do it
it was outside the box and it made me
it made me want to be healthy and at
this time i was still boxing at
him in charlotte so um
um i can tell i'm about to lose my jobs
all the little 1099 self-employed were
about to go away
they had a different change in changing
scenery for changing business
and i felt like i wasn't a culture and
fit no more so i said okay
um what i'm going to do next one but
what's my next move gonna be
and i said to myself well if i'm gonna
go through this much hell then i might
as well go through hell creating what i
want you know i'm saying because i would
hear about folks saying things about you
know
creating the business is hard is this
there in the third
like well if i'm going to go through
hell let me create my own situation
at least if it could be hard it's going
to be hard because i chose it
not because it had to be because of a
situation
so um the very first thing i did i
started cooking vegan food at my house
and delivering
i had a little food service called vegan
on the go i would cook the food deliver
it try to make money
um and i could tell i didn't like
working for i didn't like cooking for
people i did not like
the the idea that i didn't know what the
hell i was doing as far as like
inventory wise was i really making money
on without just shuffling money around
and send people food
but it was a learning experience but
during that learning experience
i remember one day walking outside with
my daughter
and i said something in the world is
going on
right here right now if i'm there early
enough i could take advantage of
because every type of type of work i
wanted to do i was always
not able to do either no degree for the
record
but i would look i'm like all right so
how did these people
make all this money i'll make all these
games like i would look at folks like
zuckerberg
like tom like uh andres
it's like yo what did what did they do
right and i looked at the internet and i
looked at technology
i'm thinking like damn all these guys
are really making good money
but why you know but why because i know
there's going to come a time where this
gets a little
for why and i realized that because they
were
early they were there early on something
that was changing the world
and i was like i need to be early on
something that would be so
the barrier of entry be so low as long
as i'm there early i can take advantage
i can make it work for me i said it out
loud one time and i was with my daughter
like i said i was in the college that
and then i remember going to a gas
station
in charlotte um i see a black dodge
charger
someone said justin what's up hey what
the hell look at this
say hey what's up man it's me isaiah i
said oh
it was idea jackson and he said yeah man
how you doing what's going on bro like
this that third so i've been knowing him
since i was 11 years old
and i tell this story all the time but
it's a very important part of the story
um so i see he says you know we catch up
he says follow me on instagram
or instagram says bitcoins i look at it
i don't know what the hell bitcoin is
but all right i got you know i'll see
you later on
stay in touch i see the movie dope
i don't really think too much of bitcoin
yet it wasn't
until my mom said hey there's um
no i'll tell you why this before that my
granddaddy who was 80 some years old at
the time
had a minor at his house a bitcoin miner
what was funny was i said what is this
granddaddy well it's the mindless
maybe some bitcoin just gonna print me
off some money
and everybody's thinking he's joking but
i'm really looking down like
what are you talking about because my
mom told me that my granddaddy
was good at finding invest he could have
invested in
i think he had opportunity investing
like enterprise microsoft very early on
i'm not sure what happened he probably
sold who knows who cares but i said all
right
if he has that type of insight that's
inside i want to have
so i started looking at bitcoin a little
bit then my mom said well hey there's
this lending platform you can use to
help you make some money
you want to give it a shot i feel you on
there it says some good hot
high quality jargon that if you invest
into this platform in 60 days we'll give
you a payout
of compounding interest i'm like yo this
sounds good all right let's go
i throw it in there i see the little
bitcoin sign i'm like all right it's
gonna work
i'll show it to jay isaiah says justin
you're about to get scammed
they're not honest it's gonna be legit
he said nah man try to take the money
out
i took the money i tried to see they
don't give him the money they did
and so then i was like damn but what
happened i didn't lose faith in bitcoin
that actually made me intrigued
it also made me intrigued me about it
because isaiah knew it was a scam just
by looking at it
i said all right so i hit him up one day
i said so i need you to tell me like you
know what's bitcoin
like what's going on he said well
he says storage value so it's like gold
appreciate some of the time he said you
can use it like money
spend it like money and it's
decentralized so the satisfied
government control now everything he
named
i kind of understood but what stood out
first was decentralization
because i could i could compare that to
how we use stamps on the prison y'all
you know if you have like a debit if you
have like an id card with a little
mag strip on it so you can swipe when
your family sends you money or you get
paid from working
you can buy things from the canteen
but but if you don't have any money on
your card then you have to use
postage stamps as currency and the value
of the postage stamps was determined by
the price
of stamps in the real world so at that
time the stamps were like
well when i was in prison that's like 44
cents as high as 45
so we always kept it at 30 or 35 cents
from the yard so you can always have
stuff in this circulation
um which is kind of ingenious so when he
told me about that you know i looked at
it
i looked at some videos um
and i said can i change my life with
this you suggesting you do whatever the
hell you want
as long as you're you have patience
you've got knowledge
you stay here and you stay active and do
whatever you want said all right
i got you so after that conversation i
had gone home i did a lot of youtube
research
a lot of youtube research see who's
talking about bitcoin see what this
is i'm digging into things i never knew
about um
i never knew about it on like gold or
just overall other stocks like i'm
hearing all this money talk
and it deals with bitcoin then i started
looking at bitcoin and i started seeing
no holes
no holes in it from what i could see
um and then i had some people i went to
school with
a lot of my friends i went to school
with you know some of them got into
finances some of them were decent
entrepreneurs
but they when i asked them about bitcoin
they said nah man we
never heard of bitcoin you know we don't
really deal with it it's not doing much
we heard about it but it's nothing
and that let me know i need to be here
because i have finally
found that that that thing
that was going to be groundbreaking in
the world but i was early enough to be
there
and those were that was what i was
looking for something
that were something that i could invest
my time and money in
but i don't have to try to worry about
being in a saturated market in three to
five years
i can already be ahead of the curve and
what i did not know then what i was
looking for
was um what i was doing was trying to be
an early adopter
so when i learned what bitcoin was you
know i still had my business i would go
through other jobs i would buy
bitcoin as much as i could um so bitcoin
at this time was like 626
i bought my first i bought my first
pieces of bitcoin around on
july 9th 2016 july 9 2016
and then i will work you know still do
my my food business so i would still try
to find jobs here and there but
i was about big i always buy bitcoin
because in my mind
i was like i've never seen my money move
i've never seen my money work for myself
i was like yo this is working for me
all right so i need to i need to go
acquire as much as possible
but then on the flip side i started
noticing like why am i always pulling
this out but why am i always having to
use it
but i wanted to grow from so that was
like a battle for a while
um but when bitcoin hit 20 000 that was
the most money i've ever had in my life
you know and it had grown for me and i
had stayed that whole course
um so when it had gone down and i was
still going through things is like you
know trying to figure out damn
how do i keep this working how do i
knock how do i not take it out
um it wasn't until it wasn't until that
bear market where i did a lot of
personal development work
um one thing in particular i did was i
signed up for jim quicks um
super brain assessment i mean of course
so i could read books fast
then i started reading up on personal
finance and reading up on how i could
actually
have bitcoin as an asset but also
buy or dollar cost average in a way that
works that's responsible
because when you start with no money you
don't have enough money to trade you
don't have enough money to play
but you have to have enough um i feel
like i had to have enough
uh reserve enough to buy into the future
so by doing that over and over and you
know having the stumbles and falls
that's what brought me here today to me
you have this incredible story
everything from kind of growing up and
the hardship that you face to then
you know literally going to prison um
and actually getting somewhat of a crash
course
in alternative currencies right most
people don't think of it with kind of
the stamps on the yard
um and then eventually finding bitcoin
and i guess really just
as you started to save in bitcoin
that's really what you were doing is you
you basically had your couple of
businesses they were driving some cash
flow when you were taking that and
converting it into bitcoin
were you doing it because you thought
that it would appreciate value did you
think it because
hey the banks can't take this from me
like what was the
kind of thought process in terms of why
you wanted to take the dollars and
convert it to bitcoin
um even before really you know 2016
there wasn't as much attention on it
given what uh what what it is today
so back then i was like okay uh
i'm cool with it the
wonderful thing the first thing that
really got my attention pop
with the fact of how easy it was to buy
right the law the barrier of entry was
incredibly low
um i didn't have to like i remember one
time someone bought up and said hey you
want to invest some
marijuana stocks with e-trade or i try
to go to these
i would try to go these platforms i'm
like just
tiring like i gotta have this or i have
to have this amount of money
but i don't have extra thousand dollars
like this you know what i mean like damn
to invest on the platform now i might
have some misinformation now
but then that was my thing and then i
got tired of dealing with the stigma of
what questions they're going to ask do i
have to you know
they're going to ask me about having my
record are they going to ask me about
this
so when they show me how to buy bitcoin
it was so simple like him this is what
decentralization feels like this is what
freedom feels like just buying it
because you can um so that was the first
thing
the second part was also the uh the fact
that it could make money
i had never purchased the asset that
could do that so to me just seeing it on
the screen go up and down
um i looked at the graphs some of the
graphs they had on instagram at that
time
and what stood out the most was the diff
you know it was the deal it was that
that that bear market time they had
from silk road when it was just going
sideways for years
that's what gave me validity because in
my mind i said that breeded real
fear in people for them to know okay i
can stay where i can go
but that's whole me this is legit
because if it just kept going going
going going going up with no dips at all
like a linear line
i thought it was some [ __ ] but i saw
this and i'm like all right well
that give that gives me that gives me
the reality to know like okay this is
worth doing
because you just don't all nothing is
leaning you just don't always go up
you have to have time of peril so that
that's what let me know that bitcoin was
legit
and that's what i said it's kind of like
life right you got
ups and downs and uh and you end up
making it where uh where you want to go
what's so fascinating to me and you and
i have talked about this before
but i think that bitcoin um has this
very special
uh kind of place in the black community
right in terms of
a lot of people have become aware of
things like predatory lending
discrimination right um and some of the
more complex things but
i think your story is so powerful
because uh
you know as somebody who had gone to
prison a lot of society
basically boxes you out right if you
have a record and so whether it was
trying to get a job at the moving
company
or trying to open up certain accounts or
participate in certain aspects of the
financial industry
maybe it's not impossible but it's
harder right and there's more friction
there
and so something like bitcoin that is
decentralized that's built on this open
protocol
nobody cares right nobody cares the
color of your skin nobody cares what
you've done in the past they just want
to know do you have the money to buy it
or do you have the collateral and i
think that maybe
you know you can shed some light just on
like as you've gone down this path and
now you know really really educated
yourself like how do you see that
and the importance for the black
community or those who've been in prison
and kind of some of these groups
of folks who who people might not be as
aware how important bitcoin is
um well the fact that there is a
friction to
traditional finances but there's
traction towards big point
does prove a lot um and
i believe when people actually
um because there are a lot of barriers
when we talk about black people
and the one way that they can really
benefit or
actually benefit from a decentralized
money in that way
is the fact that no one even the the
initial
the initial point of them even buying it
there will be a fresh air
because if i go through this friction i
know a lot of other people are going
through
as well and you know as we do
in our groups clubhouse we
we are teaching you the basics of
knowing like your money is going
backwards
you know and in the way to really that
out that i really noticed it back then
in 2016 was like this you know i do a
lot of my
i asked a lot of questions and stories
and what i experienced
so one thing i always noticed uh or very
early on was that every venture i
started
i either had to put up the money and
have to put up more money than this
money so i would always be going down
everything was a build yourself out of
debt situation
and it didn't matter what it was you
know you would have to
put up initial money it's like even uh
flipping a house or trying to really or
invest in real estate
you have to put up the collateral you
still have to continuously invest
continuously invest
whether it's maintenance whether it's um
you have to hire people no matter
whether there's bills
taxes whatever you always have to do
that even before you turn
profit on the house or even create some
type of revenue
but you got to go work for that other
money bitcoin is a situation where you
can
really set it and forget it you can buy
it
and you give it time it'll show its
appreciation
and when i speak of it from that level
i'm really trying to speak about
the freedom of of energy or the
financial freedom it gives for you to
really live in life
and you know a lot of times when it
comes to bitcoin
what we don't really experience in the
black community
is our own control over
anything like we've we never necessarily
had control over our assets we don't
really have control over our own words
hell
we came to this country as an asset and
we still have to pay capital gains tax
for being
if you really look at it so that freedom
portion
and it's it's just it's just how the
story is told to people who
who aren't necessarily open to that way
of living it
you know you when you when we were
coming up or you would hear people say
hey it's too risky to invest you know
save your money
that's what they would tell our
community but then they'll put a lottery
they'll put the lottery in our community
has a very
infinite chance of winning i mean a very
small chance of winning
but people play it all the time they
just put their money in there watch it
die
watch out watch it die nobody ever take
nobody ever took that time to actually
see where that was going
but then again like i was telling one of
my friends
we would say the government put dope in
the hood but they kept finances and
stocks and investments on their side
but you would tell black people hey you
know it's too risky you don't want to do
that saving money but you don't have no
problem with us
wasting our time and wasting our lives
selling dope or playing in these streets
with
[ __ ] so with those type of
comparisons that people that
that have to open up both eyes because
i've been talking about bitcoin all day
yeah you know the price appreciates the
disney third but for
people who never even experienced that
type of life that means nothing to them
so it's a slow introduction but one of
the greatest introductions i saw
was that i could even be in
a a bad place financially
because it might go through times i
don't have a job especially back then or
might be times things were slow
or even until you know just 2019
brother i usually make 100 like not in
2019 but when i started i used to make
150
a month sometimes and i would still go
buy bitcoin
even if it was ten dollars because i
knew this was appreciating this was
going up
and it was better for me to do that than
wasting on something else
it was a lot of different um different
areas that have to be touched
but one that i like to bring up most of
the time the people is everything you
touch
everything you've been buying before
bitcoin has been depreciating in value
or it appreciates so slowly that you
cannot keep up everything or even
even the the iphone 12 pro max you'll
buy
you could buy today you'll take it to
the pawn shop i'll tell you that i
promise you they're going to try to get
half off of what you bought so
everything depreciates why the hell are
you buying
everything you pretty much appreciate
why are you buying what you're really
highlighting here and i think is
one of the most underrated aspects of
bitcoin is uh when you start to go down
the rabbit hole of bitcoin you get a
education a monetary policy on economics
on
uh currencies on you know really the
economy and
uh you start to realize that uh the
system is working exactly as it is
designed
right but really to me it's a um a
gap between the educated and the
uneducated and not in a
a negative way it's just that's what it
is right there's people who understand
exactly what you just said that
the assets uh around you that are
consumptive
they're gonna go down in value the
investment assets are gonna go up in
value
right and it's all because the dollar is
being devalued against those investment
assets and so when you learn that your
eyes get opened and you start changing
your behavior right
right yeah that's what it was um
just noticing what appreciation was you
know just everything
um because you got a lot of times people
buy dumb [ __ ] man they buy they waste
money on expensive tubes they waste
money on weed
liquor and i mean waste like way too
much
you waste a lot of time or even right
now in bitcoin right just think about it
and i said this before and it's not to
hurt no feelings but if you're thinking
about going to
your business necessarily it's true
legacy you're probably better off just
buying bitcoin and seeing what can
happen
you know saying seeing what you can grow
from there i mean because we're at a
point in time now
where like we talked about before
michael just bought another billion
dollars
and when billionaires make these moves
what type of moves do do i feel we have
to make you know i mean
especially at the black community
there's some there's some numbers i
looked at myself like when elon made
that big buy
of 1.5 billion
i'm thinking like damn okay yeah we
i individually might not have 1.5
billion dollars right now if i pick
i'm not saying enough vote though not
saying i won't because i always feel it
no matter what the price of bitcoin is
it's a great guy i said other people all
the time they're like hey should i buy
here should i buy here
listen you're going to buy bitcoin at a
hundred thousand dollars anyway
so if it hit an all-time high of 58
thousand dollars but you still can go to
100
doesn't really matter the price of
bitcoin has been proven not to matter to
me
you know because what matters is actual
satoshi that has already been proven to
be valuable than a dollar
but um yeah so when
so once you have that reality everything
just starts becoming a little bit more
simpler to do you still want to figure
out how you want to live your life and i
think that's what's something that trips
up a lot of
blacks a lot of black people you know
like
simple things like budgeting um one of
the best books i've ever read that i
recommend
people um is profit first by mike
mcauliffe because he helped
that book helped me put money in buckets
and buy percentages
and buy you know what's important how it
matters and how you can still live your
life
by using you know still having your
business money here or what you pay
yourself like
those types of things will help open my
mind so like you said before
bitcoin helps you study economics it
helps you study you know um
global policy uh monetary policy all
that stuff then you start taking to
another level like all right
how can i really make this work for me
that was a thing
you know i realized that if i apply
the attitude to bitcoin like how rappers
do when they rap about selling dope or
being in the streets
then i know i can win like i already
have the tenacity to do it i just need
something better to go after
i didn't want to keep going after things
that were going to give me freedom
and when people actually see that then
they can really notice like yo all right
i do have the money to do something no
matter how small it is but i've been
buying [ __ ] that doesn't go nowhere
like elon elon in the cyber truck i
would not be giving him seventy thousand
dollars in bitcoin for that damn truck
and if he ever hit his podcast hit me up
i will not be doing that
only reason because that truck cannot 10
next in a year
so i've given you 70 000 and you're
going to sit on some of that bitcoin and
now you have
what a 700 000 truck because i didn't
really understand what was going on out
here with bitcoin
so but what i was going to say was i
looked at elon musk's big box
and i said all right so how could black
people as a people compete with this buy
well if we have 1.2 trillion spending
power in america
then 10 percent of that if 10 percent of
that was to go to bitcoin what would 10
percent of that be
that'll be 120 billion dollars so
will we be able to get everybody on
board i hope so
however in the very in a very good
stages
why i like to say is you know put 10 of
whatever you get
first based upon how i read the profits
first because you got to pay yourself in
the beginning
so many times we pay our sweet what we
give ourselves in the future is debt
[ __ ] like you you re you receive
money
like oh yeah i'm good but you remember
you got to pay off a debt
from six months ago that's 80 of your
money i started looking at money in
percentages
and so if we take that approach as a
people
10 percent of our spending power from
what we're doing usd to bitcoin
then as a as a collection we'll be worth
120 billion dollars
in btc now you allow that to index what
would that be
but that's how i had to start looking at
bitcoin and i know like that's very far
out
but however it's a mission that i love
to be a part of
with everything we do at clubhouse big
black uh black bitcoin millionaires and
bsa and lamar wilson but
that's just how i started looking at
bitcoin as is that freedom piece
but it does start at a very ground level
again people understand what the hell
bitcoin
and why it's beneficial for them
absolutely
no it it it is uh bitcoin is beautiful
and i think the way you describe it
is perfect um i know that you recently
wrote a a book
uh it's uh when the ocean or in the
ocean uh that is filled with sharks be
the orca talk a little bit about the
book and uh explain the title and kind
of what the
the goal with the book is so
the really how i got to the title man i
used to always like watching
national geographic um even though i'm a
vegan i'm gonna tell people like this
even though i'm a vegan i like watching
animals eat other animals
i don't know why i mean [ __ ] these stuff
some of us will tell me well that's not
nature like nah that's nature that's
what they're supposed to do
you know i might not eat meat but i love
watching the lion eat some [ __ ] up
so um so
what really got to me one day man i was
online and
um you know you hear the word apex
predator right
what the hell is that one day they were
talking about a commodore dragon being
the apex president
of his land and his real lives like you
know he can't be hunted
he can't be hunted like when he's on
that island
he can't be hunted everything matter of
fact i'm so much of an apex brother i i
control population i'm population
that's what it comes dragging me so then
you know i heard that word i didn't
really
buy into it so much but i was watching
something online
and it was you know they were in the
water and they were talking about how
the orca is the apex
predator street the wolves of the sea
and usually you would think
it's the shark most people think well
the strike is the baddest [ __ ]
water
until you start looking at the
characteristics
and i remember one time i was uh i was i
was at a function by this guy
by this coach by the name of jc fox and
we always talk about being the top one
percent
and striving to be there and i was like
all right that makes sense
so i'm studying this orchid i'm looking
at like why is this
why is he the apex president not just
because of size
it's more intelligent than the shark
they communicate they work together
and they have high they have highly
advanced hunting techniques
so i took that and i just looked at like
how i've been living my life to approach
becoming the top the top of whatever i'm
in
and so there's a dif the reason i wrote
that book is number one so you can see
how how i approach my life to get to
where i am
the relentless pursuit behind it but
also where i strive to be you know i
didn't just strive to be
i don't strive to be uh in the know i
don't strive to be you know
one of the best i strive to be the
authority i strive for greatness because
when you throw out a big goal whatever
you hit in the middle is gonna be it's
gonna be a good result but you want four
only because of where i started only
because of where it was only because of
the legacy i wanted for my family
so the point of the book is to highlight
everywhere i've gone in my life
um i liked the the the effort and
mentality it took
and some of the things i saw how i just
applied when i saw the life
that's how i had to really learn a lot
of things off of the mistakes i made
how i'm going to write these mistakes
who i'm going to listen to
who i'm going to surround myself by you
know i mean orcas work in pods they work
in groups
so i learn like lean on your network
user network
value being a part of a big network for
a
quality of network and that's how i look
at bitcoin
you know if we have 8 billion people in
the world and 100 million people
use bitcoin now or less than that that
means you have
at least what one one to two percent of
the global population already here
i started valuing those types of numbers
because there's a different caliber
that's a different color network there's
a different caliber of people
that are there so once you strive and
now and that's what i talk about a lot
just striving to be the best of the best
no matter who it is your friend can make
quote-unquote competition with you make
a healthy competition do whatever
but that's the only way i started to get
out of my situation
because every athlete you know every
athlete i named floyd he fought his way
out of a dang bedroom the size of this
office with seven other kids there
tyler perry slept on a [ __ ] created
what he created
tom brady got picked 199 i mean yo
none of these people who were great
thought it was going to be an easy role
they just accepted what it was and went
through it
that's why i wrote about the book and
that's how i approach everything i do
you know
if i if i have to start at this level
all right cool
as long as i have the tools i need to
get there then i'm gonna get there but
just do it
because what it looks like what it looks
like right now doesn't mean it's gonna
always look like this
so i gave that book to talk about every
experience i went
every experience i went and to show
people like there
really is not to get what the hell you
want to do
you just have to be committed to
whatever it takes whatever's in the
process to get there you get there
and if you die along the way guess what
that was what it was meant to be
but dedicate to it you have to dedicate
something that's what
that's where the purpose that's where
that book comes from came from
that's the purpose of me writing yeah
where can people go
find the book right now if they want to
find it um well they could find
i have it on my website bitcoinvegan.com
there's a pre-sale going on
first 100 people to buy i will send them
an autographed copy
of bitcoin vegan.com and you can
press the little shop page and you'll
see the book at the top
or if you're on instagram you can you
know click the link in the bio
and you'll see it there too as well but
it's on my website bitcoinvegan.com
you got it uh you got wired up there um
before
we get into the rapid fire questions i
want to talk about this idea of no
excuses
um but i know that you and uh and zay
have talked a bunch about it but just
this idea that
you know look you basically uh have the
the perfect story
which is uh you had hardship in your
life you went to prison
and you got out and you made a better
life for yourself right
and if you can do it anyone can do it
right because
basically it would be really easy for
you to sit there and say uh you know
i i had this bad situation happen and
therefore i kind of have a disadvantage
in life now
and so you know i'm just gonna take the
lumps and uh and it is what it is but
instead you said no
i'm not gonna allow that to be the
narrative and so talk a little bit about
this idea of like no excuses and
and why you think anyone in the world
can do this
well i like how you say the narrative
because
i hate i hate false narratives i hate
narratives that i didn't agree to
like no one said that i was gonna fall
like for instance
me going home going to prison coming
home everybody says it's gonna be hard
or just that a third i said no nowhere
did i agree or did i tell you i wasn't
reaching that [ __ ] there
i didn't tell you none of that so you
know i love to rewrite a narrative if i
can
um and when it comes to excuses man you
know the what what helped me realize i
was making excuses
was when i looked at the people who i
was surrounded by
what were they allowing me to make true
oh i can't do this yeah you're right man
you know
just fall back just relax you know i
started listen i started studying what
excuses work
from high level mediocre excuses from
very
very bomb excuses excuses in general you
know what am i telling my telling myself
that i cannot do
and when i looked at when i just looked
at my life i really felt
like i felt like even in prison i was
going to come out and still be
successful but
i think it was um i'll tell you when i
read a book by grant cardone who said
don't nobody care what you think you
cannot do
like if you want to be a successful
nobody care what you think you cannot do
what can you do you have to be able to
do something what the hell can you do
in prison we had to use everything
around this and still make it better
you know pump i use i use what
batteries and headphones and tape to to
uh
to charge himself on the prison you know
and i've seen a guy
with several life sentences hustle his
way to hire
laura to get a to get a release date you
know i've seen people
who fight for their fight for what they
want i i when i came home from prison i
spent a lot of time
at dime boxing gym here in charlotte i
was always around fighters they never
gave up
they never gave up it was always about
fighting for your life what no matter
what it is
so nobody care about what you cannot do
and that's when i realized my excuse
really don't live here even when it
comes to bitcoin well i can't afford
a thousand dollars well can you buy one
satoshi yeah well it's better than
buying doge
it doesn't matter like it was all about
being
it was all about being present noticing
myself
what am i telling myself i can't do and
why
you know what where where did i where
did i agree to this in my past
who did i put myself around who i
thought was you know
on the level of success but now i'm
noticing their excuse
now i always study i like to study
people i like to study business i like
to study
people and see what they say when
obstacles come up
because no matter where you are there's
going to be offer
you know it's like a video game when we
play video games growing up you go to
level one you beat that level you beat
the level at level two there's another
boss there there's another boss there
there's always someone
or something you have to overcome at any
level so i had to get over the fact that
this [ __ ] was gonna be a linear straight
process
and be okay with whatever confronted me
to go to that next level
i stopped looking at i stopped looking
at quote-unquote excuses or reasons not
to do something as a reason to do it
because whatever whenever i overcome
this excuse here
i'll be ready to ascend to whatever the
next level has for me
and whatever comes at that level so it
was about me really looking at the
journey and realizing that all
journeys come with options and you have
to be prepared
to step toward that option every single
moment if you look at
look at how tom looks in the last two
minutes of the first six super bowls he
was always ready for
like how floyd looks like when he steps
into the ring he's always ready for it
they are always ready for whatever takes
place and no matter what
it took place between there you have to
you have to be
willing to accept accept the fact that
you could lose it could turn out bad but
you still did it
and take what you learned and keep going
at the end of the day you have time on
your side you'll always make
you always i love it i can talk to you
forever man
uh before i let you go i got i got a
three rapid fire questions then you
could ask me one to uh to finish up
uh what is the most important book that
you've ever read
so outside of bitcoin in black america
by their jackson
i will i will say this and i really hope
these guys hear this because i would
love to meet these two
the future is faster than you think by
steven caller and peter dominator
uh that book was so impactful for me
especially in 2020 because
i had told myself i don't i wanted like
well i thought i was taking that
jim quick course and started reading off
crazy books i read
i would read like 10 books a month just
on things i knew i was not good at
and then get better at those things if i
could create revenue to hire somebody to
do it
do it that's how i approach life again
everything is out here
everything's out you got to read books
and do it do it but when i read that
book i want to start reading books up
really
up today like they came out fresh so
when i read that book
the book came out january 28 2020. i
read that book
in about two or three days and it opened
up to me
everything that was possible to take
place in this decade
it even made i hate to say it it made
coronavirus make sense
because how else would we start bringing
this stuff in
it made bitcoin make even better systems
but most importantly that book opened my
mind up to what the future
is where the future is going i've always
been about where is the world headed now
where the hell is it
that's why i didn't want to hop into a
lot of things that my friends are
already doing
because it's like yo it's gonna be
saturated five years in five years i
might as well
struggle with some [ __ ] that's
disruptive or that's coming out
it's gonna be exponential so in that
five years i could be hey justin we want
you on pomp show
instead of being like hey justin come
come to work those are the differences i
wanted so
future is fascinating you think it's
possibly outside of bitcoin in black
america
and every other damn book i'm a name one
of the most
important books to read in this decade
that's a great uh
suggestion second question is a little
bit more personal your sleep schedule so
i used to be like a six hour sleeper
uh and then mateo and alex over at eight
sleep convinced me
uh so this question's brought to uh to
us by them
uh they got like a thermo-regulated bed
basically means it is making it really
cold so i sleep it on an ice cube all
sudden i sleep like a babies get deep
sleep
feel better uh and not try to eight nine
hours what's your sleep schedule now and
how has that evolved over the years
well now with a newborn baby that thing
hard
the baby changes everything huh yeah
it's almost not there oh but before
then i would say this so and i like what
you said about sleeping in the cold
because
i read that with jim quick he said like
you know when you turn the temperature
down
it tells your body like you're ready to
sleep um keep it pitch back dark
he brought out some amazing stuff
because you want your fellow synthesis
to be down
uh so really i would wake up i used to
i used to always wake up at 5 00 a.m
like i said before i had my baby
and they would you know do things um but
i feel like sleep is very important
because you get to this was something
some cool [ __ ] he said too
he said you get to solve the problems
you had from the previous day
so my sleep schedule would usually
consist of me trying to get
if not eight uh if not eight hours
or six six to eight hours of good sleep
and if it's not going to be that long of
sleep then i want my quality of sleep to
be very good
i want to be in a deep sleep so my brain
can really relax
and really um really be productive for
the next day
so a good a good i try to get a good six
to eight hours
um and i just want it's just the quality
of sleep now it's just the quality of
sleep i can get
and you know the older this this baby
boy gets
i know the better sleep will get so yeah
hey i i i love it i love it uh
last question for you is uh aliens are
you a uh believer or a non-believer
listen man somewhere now people i get
some flack about this from people but
sometimes i think to tell she's an alien
um i do actually believe i don't i can't
sit here and believe we're the only
people out here um it's kind of it's
kind of strange
um you know i hope to go to mars one day
hopefully bitcoin can get me there i
really feel like i can go uh
but i do believe in aliens i do believe
in life outside of earth
i believe they're so intelligent that
they that they can that they can see us
but we can't see them
or somebody knows about them that
they're not just going out telling that
information but
i do believe in aliens and i am
interested in uh being on mars
when that time come hey i'll be there
with you let's go
what are they saying bitcoins going to
the moon and uh
and humans are going to mars i'm i'm
down for it uh
you get asked me one you get asked me
one question finish up what you got for
me
ah one question for you
oh man
i never had to ask the question on the
flip side
let's talk about something real like i
don't know if you'd like to do this or
not but we're going to throw it out
there
what's your price prediction for bitcoin
by the end of the
oh year i keep the same thing i've been
saying for years 100k by the end of 2021
i ain't changing it
uh i'm kind of being too concerned i'm
trying to be i'm probably being too
conservative at this point
uh but i just that's the number i picked
so like whatever i'm sticking with it
i mean i feel y'all i can hold hard i
can i remember i read between november
this last year someone from city bank
saw
300 000 and reason i
see that happening sometimes i read
different
uh articles and i read one in particular
where it said the wall street journal
was talking about a cash crisis
and you couple that with um
the endless amounts of printing of money
that you love tweeting us about that
and man you know you do a better job
tweeting the price employee market cap
uh man i love it i love it oh and you
were talking
from jazz to somebody else the other day
good job i love that too
but um but everything with you know
including the print of money
uh loss of jobs we're going to continue
to get more stimulus checks and they're
talking about the cash prices well
they're down
how can there be one that's going to
keep printing it i just see
and i in the couple that with bitcoin
just being the orange pill and opening
folks minds up to
the reality that's in front of them i
mean
100k in the years are bad i can't see
300 000.
you know 100k is only a 2x now so
hey just everything is possible anything
is possible
so where can people find you if they
want to get in touch with you on
social media uh find me on instagram
at bitcoinvegan you can find me at
twitter at bitcoin underscore vegan
simply shoot me an email justin at
bitcoinvegan.com
awesome man listen just thank you so
much for taking the time to do this
you've got a
incredible story you're doing a
fantastic work and hopefully we'll do
this again in the future